languages change over time but you
already know that much if you've gone
through my intro to language history
you've seen how an individual word
changes as it passes from a proto
language into related daughter languages
where it transforms into distinct words
called cognates the differences between
cognates show up most noticeably in the
way the words sound we were able to use
these differences to spot sound
correspondences that mark cognates in
their related languages but also to
recognize the sound changes that
separate the daughter languages from
their common parent in this series we'll
take a closer look at the types of sound
change that shape the history of
languages and language families all
around the world foreign and familiar
alike historical linguistics often split
sound change into two halves regular
changes versus irregular changes a
regular sound change takes place
systematically and in every instance of
an environment for example if a language
undergoes a sound change where Erb
becomes pronounced blue every a will
change to a if in that same language mmm
turns into mm between a vowel and a B
then every M found after a vowel and
before a B will undergo that sound
change early in the 20th century the
regularity hypothesis proposed that all
sound change naturally works this way
irregular sound changes are quirky in
nature they're actually known as
sporadic sound changes because the sound
change doesn't occur routinely in a
given environment let's take an example
from English some older dialects of
English pronounce the word for a male
fox fox and the word for a female of the
species fixing in other dialects the two
words started with a vous thanks to
dialect mixing modern English speakers
inherited a bit of both
leaving us with Fox and
Vixen the change from Germanic foot to
modern English vu in Vixen is sporadic
since it doesn't match up with any
regular across-the-board sound change in
modern English to understand sporadic
sound change we'd really need to look
into the features of local dialects and
regional language patterns that's at
least the case in the Fox vixen example
I gave where the two words descend from
two different dialects we are going to
attempt to uncover the background behind
that kind of sound change here instead
the topic of regular sound change will
be the order of the day this series will
look at the various types of regular
pronunciation change that are common to
languages around the world be they
foreign languages like Japanese and
Arabic or native ones like English will
also see how these changes very often
make combinations of sounds easier to
pronounce in other words one of the key
motivations for speakers to change a
sound is ease of articulation for any
viewers who aren't yet familiar with
language change in reconstructed
languages I'll leave you with another
link to that series also since we're
going to focus on the change part of
sound change you'll need a basic
understanding of sounds if that's where
you're at check out this video series
first in the next video it's on to the
various processes of sound change
starting with assimilation thanks for
watching
you